so good evening so this is an important
evening and dinner tonight you know that
the Western Balkans are a priority for
our Commission and I think it's in our
common geostrategic interest to have the
Western Balkans as close as possible to
the European Union you know that we have
revised our methodology and the
methodology in its revised form should
create and regain trust on all sides in
this process because it is accelerating
the structural reforms and on the other
hand it is creating a credible
perspective for the Western Balkans to
join over time the European Union we
want also to pave the way for North
Macedonia and Albania to start the
accession talks with the European Union
if possible for the Zagreb before the
Zagreb summit for the summit itself we
are preparing an investment package by
the Commission and I hope very much that
the council will give now green light
for this prospect we will have tomorrow
for Albania a donor's conference the
donors conference has the aim to create
a lot of pledging money for the
reconstruction after the difficult
earthquake that has taken place in
Albania thank you